[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen was heute im Sport passiert
ist das erfahren Sie von Norbert Lehmann
einen schönen guten Abend unsere großen
Themen im Überblick
Russland meldet ukrainische Offensive
die Ukraine habe schwere Verluste
erlitten Kiew dementiert und spricht von
Desinformation
auf der Suche nach Fachpersonal die
Bundesregierung hofft in Brasilien vor
allem Pflegekräfte für Deutschland zu
finden
ein fußballweltstar sagt Ciao Zlatan
Ibrahimovic der Schwede mit den großen
Toren und genauso großen
Selbstbewusstsein beendet seine Karriere
[Musik]
russland hat im Angriffskrieg nach
eigenen Angaben eine große ukrainische
Gegenoffensive abgewehrt dabei seien
mehr als 900 Ukrainer getötet worden so
ein russischer armee-sprecher das ist
sich dabei tatsächlich um einen großen
Gegenschlag gehandelt hat weiß die
Ukraine zurück
unverweist auf eigene Geländegewinne um
die Stadt bachmut über den Kriegsverlauf
berichtet Antoine
ukrainische Panzer im Einsatz bei
bachmut wir rücken vor sagt ein
Kommandeur dabei sein russische
Stellungen zerstört worden was diese
Bilder vom ukrainischen Militär belegen
sollen ihr sollt eine Truppe Wagner
kämpft ob der Seite der Russen ihr Chef
prigoshi räumte heute ein dass die
Ukraine Teile von bachmut zurückerobert
habe die Russen hauen ab sagt prigoschin
das sei eine Schande Moskau meldet dass
die ukrainische Offensive bei Woche im
Osten begonnen hat und veröffentlicht
als belegt diese Aufnahmen zu sehen
ukrainische Einheiten unter Feuer
am 4 Juni hat der Feind eine groß
angelegte Offensive an der Front in der
Region jetzt gestartet daran beteiligt
auch zwei panzerbataione der Feind
wollte unsere Verteidigungslinien
durchbrechen aber er hat seine Ziele
nicht erreicht
dem widerspricht ein russischer
feldkommandour er sagt die ukrainische
Offensive werde Zitat von Erfolg
begleitet hier spricht heute von
offensiven Aktionen an einigen
Frontabschnitten
das ist ein taktisches Geplänkel also
ein Gefecht dass ich ja noch nicht voll
entwickelt hat da muss man noch abwarten
man kann ja in wenigen Stunden eine
größere Offensive überhaupt nicht
entwickeln sehen sondern dass wir Tage
und vielleicht sogar Wochen in Anspruch
nehmen das ukrainische Militär hatte
gestern diese Bilder veröffentlicht da
lautete die Botschaft wir verraten euch
nicht wann die Offensive beginnt
und vor Ort in der Ukraine ist für uns
Tim Krüger Tim was wir jetzt sehen ist
das jetzt der Beginn der ukrainischen
Großoffensive oder nicht
also das ist im Moment noch schwer
einzuschätzen klar ist nur das an
verschiedenen Teilen an der Front
gekämpft wird dass es ukrainische
Angriffe gibt dass das ukrainische
Vorstöße gibt und das deutet darauf hin
dass tatsächlich einiges dort an der
Front passiert aber wir wissen eben
nicht ob das im Moment noch kleinere
taktische Operationen sind oder ob das
wirklich der Beginn der erwarteten
ukrainischen Offensive ist die
ukrainische stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin die hat sich
heute zu Wort gemeldet und sie hat
tatsächlich bestätigt dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte in einigen
Sektoren an der Front zu offensiven
Aktionen übergegangen sind sie hat aber
eben auch gesagt dass diese Aktion eher
lokale Bedeutung haben und dass diese
Vorstöße sich im Moment auf bachmut
konzentrieren also dass das nach wie vor
das Zentrum ist das sind schon mal
einige Informationen die wir da von
Seiten der Ukraine bekommen haben aber
um wirklich ein genaues ein klares Bild
zu bekommen von dem was sein in
verschiedenen Front abgeschnitten
passiert und was das für eine Bedeutung
hat dazu müssen wir noch weitere
Informationen warten danke schön Tim
Krüger
Russlands Marine demonstriert Stärke
einen Tag nach der NATO hat sie auf der
Ostsee ebenfalls ein groß angelegtes
Manöver begonnen mit bis zu 40 Schiffen
sowie rund 3.500 Soldaten man wolle
unter anderem die Verteidigung der
eigenen flottenbasen üben so dass
russische Militär das Manöver soll bis
zum 15 Juni dauern
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist heute bei der
Deutschen Marine Rostock er will sich
dort ein Bild von der Leistungsfähigkeit
der Seestreitkräfte machen auch vor dem
Hintergrund einer veränderten
Sicherheitslage in Europa Anna Stadtfeld
berichtet
die Fregatte Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in
der Ostsee vor Rostock erstmals seit
sieben Jahren ist ein Kanzler wieder zu
Besuch bei der Deutschen Marine Olaf
Scholz hat sich einige Übungen zeigen
lassen aufgrund der veränderten
Sicherheitslage durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine gewinnen
die Seestreitkräfte wieder am Bedeutung
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir uns
überall
zusammentun im Rahmen der NATO dass wir
gemeinsam üben dass wir uns vorbereiten
und noch zeigen dass wir in der Lage
sind das Bündnis und die Mitgliedstaaten
die Demokratie und die Freiheit zu
verteidigen deutschland hat mit
Jahresbeginn die Führung der schnellen
Eingreiftruppe der NATO übernommen an
der auch die Marine an der Ostsee
beteiligt ist die Fregatte
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist zurzeit das
Flaggschiff in einem NATO-Einsatz und
kehrt auch nach diesem Einsatz für den
antrittsversuch des Bundeskanzlers
wieder dahin zurück das zeigt die neue
Stärke der Bundesmarine auch hier im
Ostseeraum es ist der größte Player im
NATO verbunden bis 20 35 will die
Deutsche Marine aufrüsten neue
Kriegsschiffe haben oberste Priorität
größtes Problem der Marine die internen
Prozesse seien zu langsam sagen Kritiker
insbesondere muss die Lieferung von
Material muss deutlich schneller werden
dieser ganze Bürokratismus der herrscht
in den Streitkräften muss abgeschafft
werden muss abgebaut werden damit es
einfach schneller gehen kann und wir
brauchen Personal die Ostsee ist in den
kommenden Wochen Schauplatz zweier groß
angelegter Manöver der NATO auf der
einen Seite und Russland auf der anderen
beiden Akteuren ist es wichtig Stärke zu
zeigen
deutschland braucht dringend Fachkräfte
vor allem in der Pflege
Abhilfe konnte aus dem Ausland kommen
zum Beispiel aus Brasilien dort sind
Außenministerin berburg und
Arbeitsminister Heil gerade auf
Werbetour denn bisher läuft die
Anwerbung nur sehr schleppend laut
Stiftung Patientenschutz kamen im
vergangenen Jahr rund 100 Pflegerinnen
und Pfleger aus EU-Staaten nach
Deutschland aus nicht EU-Ländern waren
es 656
zu wenig um der Personalnot entgegen zu
wirken aus Brasilia berichtet Andrea
Maurer
eine Pflegeschule in der brasilianischen
Hauptstadt Brasilien der deutsche
Arbeitsminister will gut ausgebildete
Pflegekräfte für Deutschland anwerben in
Brasilien einen Job zu finden ist
schwierig die jungen Pfleger mit denen
wir sprechen würden kommen
wir hören dass es die Möglichkeit gibt
in Deutschland zu arbeiten für uns ist
das eine gute Idee
deutschland braucht Fachkräfte wie Artur
dringend sagt die Vorstände in der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die mitgekommen
ist nach Brasilia die Pflege ist unter
den engpass-berufen auf Top 5 es dauert
sehr sehr lange bis wir Stellen besetzt
bekommen im Pflegebereich 267 Tage Heil
unterzeichnet auch eine gemeinsame
Absichtserklärung mit dem
brasilianischen Arbeitsminister für
faire Einwanderung um etwa Lohndumping
zu verhindern ich möchte dass das fair
organisiert wird aber wir brauchen das
wissen auch die Menschen die in der
Pflege arbeiten ergänzen zu den
inländischen Potenzialen auch helfen der
Hände und klugeköpfe auseinander in den
letzten Jahren war das politische werben
um Pflegekräfte im Ausland wenig
erfolgreich die Reise ist Teil der neuen
Fachkräfte an Werbestrategie der Ampel
auch die Außenministerin ist in
Brasilien dabei bürokratische Hürden
sollen abgebaut Visa Vergabe und
Familiennachzug erleichtert werden
das Unterfangen ist sensibel laut
Weltgesundheitsorganisation sollte kein
Land dem anderen medizinisch notwendiges
Fachpersonal wegnehmen gleichzeitig hat
Brasilien eine Arbeitslosenquote von
zehn Prozent im Pflegebereich die
Win-Win-Situation von der der
Arbeitsminister hier heute spricht sieht
so aus Deutschland bekommt dringend
benötigtes Fachpersonal Brasilien
profitiert weil sich Deutschland bei der
Ausbildung vor Ort engagiert
200 brasilianische Pflegekräfte arbeiten
derzeit schon in Deutschland
perspektivisch sollen 700 pro Jahr
kommen
das Ziel ist es also ausländische
Fachkräfte nach Deutschland zu holen
einige Unternehmen hier versuchen das
bereits auf eigene Faust wie groß die
Hürden dabei sind hat sich Markus Weise
angeschaut
mittlerweile kennen sich Victoria und
Letizia gut aus die Kanüle wechseln die
Pflege Azubis routiniert für Ihren
Traumjob haben sie in Brasilien alles
hinter sich gelassen Familie Freunde ihr
ganzes Leben sie fühlen sich wohl in
Deutschland und auch verzweifeln sie
immer wieder an Bürokratie und
mangelnder Digitalisierung
ich habe gar nichts verstanden mein
erster Tag ich wollte schon zurück nach
Brasilien ich habe viel geweint
zumindest ich mache das auf mich ich
will meine beste Leben von den rund 1,7
Millionen Beschäftigten in den
Pflegeberufen sind 244000 aus dem
Ausland seit 2017 hat sich ja Anteil
verdoppelt hier in Neu-Isenburg werden
sie dafür ausgebildet viele Stunden
Praxis und natürlich Deutsch pauken
damit es nicht an der Sprachbarriere
schaltet die Nachfrage ist da doch die
Hürden zu groß fatal im Kampf gegen den
Pflegenotstand
die Behörden arbeiten viel zu langsam
die anerkennungsprozesse dauern viel zu
lange die Visa werden schleppender teilt
der Bundesverband Pflegemanagement
kritisiert deshalb die Reise nach
Brasilien sei unnötig wir brauchen keine
Unterstützung in der Anwerbung im
Ausland wir brauchen jetzt hier in
Deutschland ganz schnell die
Anerkennungsverfahren tatsächlich viel
besser zu strukturieren schneller
einheitlicher digitaler im nächsten Jahr
werden Victoria und Letizia mit ihrer
Ausbildung fertig sein sie haben viel
auf sich genommen um in Deutschland
arbeiten zu können
die Staatsanwaltschaft Halle hat Anklage
gegen Björn höcke erhoben den
Fraktionschef der AFD in Thüringen ihm
wird vorgeworfen Kennzeichen einer
nationalsozialistischen Organisation
öffentlich verwendet zu haben konkret
geht es um die verbotene sa-lösung alles
für Deutschland die er bei einer
Wahlkampfrede in Sachsen-Anhalt
verwendet haben soll höcke habe Herkunft
und Bedeutung der Formel gekannt so die
Staatsanwaltschaft
die EU liegt seit Jahren mit der
Nationalkonservativen Regierung in Polen
im Streit Brüssel sieht durch mehrere
Justizreform die Rechtsstaatlichkeit in
Polen bedroht im Mittelpunkt die
Unabhängigkeit der Richterinnen und
Richter die nicht gewährleistet sei ein
weiterer Kritikpunkt polnischem Recht
werde ein Vorrang vor EU-Recht
eingeräumt nun hat der Europäische
Gerichtshof entschieden Teile der
Justizreform verstoßen gegen Unionsrecht
Christoph Schneider mit Einzelheiten
als am frühen Nachmittag der Europäische
Gerichtshof in Luxemburg seine
Entscheidung verkündet ist klar der
Umbau des polnischen Justizsystems von
2019 verstößt gegen europäisches Recht
und schlägt sich in Grundsätzen nieder
die rechtlich bindende Verpflichtung für
die Mitgliedstaaten enthalten damit hat
die Klage der EU-Kommission gegen Polen
Erfolg systematisch hatte die polnische
Regierung über Jahre immer wieder die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit ausgehöhlt was auf
Protest schließt und besonders die
inzwischen wieder abgeschaffte
disziplinar kann man für Richterinnen
und Richter habe die Unabhängigkeit
untergraben nicht hinnehmbar und
entsprechend sanktioniert
die Richter im Europäischen Gerichtshof
haben heute eine deutliche rote Linie
gezogen denn sie sagen mit ihrem Urteil
ganz klar Polens Regierung hat die
Unabhängigkeit der Gerichte beschnitten
und wer das tut erschüttert einen
Rechtsstaat in seinen Grundfesten denn
Justiz ohne unabhängige Gerichte
funktioniert schlicht nicht das bislang
vom Europäischen Gerichtshof gegen Polen
verhängte Zwangsgeld wegen der
Nichtbeachtung rechtsstaatlicher
Grundsätze von zunächst einer Million
Euro am Tag wurde Mitte April auf eine
halbe Millionen Euro pro Tag reduziert
mit dem Urteil jetzt läuft das
Zwangsgeld aus eine Entscheidung des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs mit
Signalwirkung für ganz Europa
Isabel Schäfers in Brüssel ja welches
Signal geht von diesem Urteil aus
ja das ist natürlich zunächst mal eine
klare juristische Ansage an Polen aber
das Urteil zeigt auch die politische
Dimension des Problems noch mal auf und
das ist die fehlende Handhabe im
derzeitigen Zustand würde wohl Polen
wohl kaum noch mal EU-Mitglied werden
aber einmal drinnen der Union hat die
EU-Kommission relativ wenig
Möglichkeiten vorzugehen sie kann Gelder
einbehalten aber auch das hat ja in der
Vergangenheit relativ wenig gebracht
bisher und dann sind die
rechtsstaatsverletzung von Polen in den
letzten Monaten auch etwas von der
politischen Agenda hier verschwunden
denn Polen anders als Ungarn unterstützt
die EU-Politik zur Unterstützung der
Ukraine und da haben einige
Mitgliedstaaten jetzt auch einige Zeit
etwas weggeschaut was in Polen passiert
dieses Urteil ruft jetzt aber noch mal
in Erinnerung so schnell wird sich in
Polen die Situation nicht grundlegend
ändern und es ist wohl auch etwas kurz
gegriffen einfach auf einen Machtwechsel
bei den Wahlen im Herbst zu hoffen was
es braucht ist ein politischer Wille für
eine echte Lösung beim Umgang mit
regelbrechern hier in der EU und so eine
Lösung kann natürlich kein Gericht
liefern
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
Isabel
nächstes Jahr sind ja
Präsidentschaftswahlen in den USA und da
will nun auch der frühere US
Vizepräsident Mike Pens für die
Republikaner antreten der ehemalige Vize
unter Donald Trump hat dazu Unterlagen
bei der bundeswahlkommission eingereicht
die offizielle Ankündigung wird für
diesen Mittwoch erwartet
künstliche Intelligenz soll stärker
reguliert werden so fordert die
EU-Kommission das Texte und Bilder die
mit Hilfe künstliche Intelligenz
geschaffen worden sind auch entsprechend
gekennzeichnet werden
Internetnutzer sollten klar erkennen
können dass bestimmte Inhalte nicht von
Menschen geschaffen worden sein sagte
die zuständige EU-Kommissarin jurowa der
Umgang mit KI ist auch Thema auf Europas
größter Konferenz über die digitale
Gesellschaft der re:publica in Berlin
Nil Schneider
auf der re:publica in Berlin treffen
sich die für die künstliche Intelligenz
schon lange nichts Neues mehr ist die
Technologie entwickelt sich in rasendem
Tempo die Anwendungsgebiete betreffen
immer mehr Lebensbereiche wir brauchen
auf jeden Fall gesetzliche
Rahmenbedingungen für künstliche
Intelligenz damit ihr auch besser
gedeihen kann und damit wir diesen
Technologien auch vertrauen können das
heißt wir brauchen einen
Nachvollziehbarkeit es muss
offensichtlich sein
ob wir gerade mit einer KI kommunizieren
oder mit einem Menschen auf der
digitalkonferenz haben die Besucher
unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu gerade
sehe ich persönlich noch nicht so die
große Gefahr ist noch im
Entwicklungsstadium ist man muss das
allerdings sicherlich noch beobachten
aber etwas gleich von Anfang stark
regulieren nein ich glaube schon dass KI
auf jeden Fall eine gewisse Regulierung
braucht einfach aus dem Grund dass
ja auch viele Jobs dadurch verloren
gehen können aktuell wäre es wichtig
Verbraucher besser aufzuklären
Entscheidungen von Computerprogrammen
mit KI sind nicht immer korrekt und vor
allem nicht immer kompetent und das sind
solche Dinge wie creditscoring also
Bonitätsprüfung das sind
gesichtserkennungssysteme die Menschen
zum Beispiel zu verdächtigen machen auch
wenn sie überhaupt im Grunde genommen
nichts verbrochen haben das sind Systeme
die in unserem Alltag bereits vorkommen
und die immer stärker Verbreitung finden
und den müssen wir Fesseln anlegen KI
hat großen Nutzen birgt aber auch
Risiken es gilt einen Kompromiss zu
schaffen zwischen Fortschritt und
Sicherheit
und jetzt kommen wir zur
Fußball-Bundesliga Norbert Hamburg oder
Stuttgart das ist ja heute Abend die
Frage ja Aufstieg oder Abstieg der VfB
ist ja ganz nah dran am Klassen erhalten
nach dem Souverän 13:0 Heimsieg im
Relegationsspiel der HSV dagegen braucht
schon ein Mittel schweres Fußballwunder
sonst droht das sechste Jahr in Folge
die zweite katzigkeit
für hamburgstrainer Tim Walter ist sein
Team stark genug für das Wunder denn in
den letzten zehn Heimspielen gelangen in
Hamburg durchschnittlich drei Tore pro
spielen ist sie nicht blauäugig sondern
wir sind professionell ist es nicht
unmöglich und und das werden wir auch
probieren zum fünften Mal versucht der
HSV den Sprung in die erste Liga in der
letzten Saison sind sie noch an der
Berliner Hertha gescheitert und diesmal
es geht schon darum dass wir nur als
Team wenn jeder 100% abliefern kann eine
Chance haben im hinspielgerät Hamburg
schon nach 46 Sekunden durch das
schnelle Tor vom VfB und verunsicherten
Hamburgern gelangen im ganzen Spiel nur
diese eine gefährliche Aktion
Stuttgarter dagegen er spielte Chance
und Chance und mit dem 13.0 Endergebnis
eine sehr gute Grundlage für den
Klassenerhalt nicht schon wieder zweite
Liga der HSV kämpft für ein ziemlich
großes Wunder
er war ein ganz großer im Fußball nicht
nur körperlich ein großartiger Stürmer
und auch ein großartiger
Selbstdarstellers Latein Ibrahimovic der
41-Jährige Schwede hat gestern Abend in
Mailand seinen Abschied als Fußballprofi
verkündet
ein Mann der Emotionen ein Mann mit
ausgeprägtem Selbstbewusstsein ein Mann
der einer der größten Fußballer der
Geschichte wurde Zlatan Ibrahimovic ich
habe eine lange lange Karriere gehabt
und ich bin dankbar und glücklich
ein Kind jugoslawischer Migranten aus
ärmsten Verhältnissen mit großem Willen
und herausragendem Talent erste
internationale Station Ajax Amsterdam
die Ablösesummen für das geniale enfond
terrible werden immer größer so wie die
Vereine die ihn nach und nach abwerben
122 Länderspiele für Schweden mit der
Rekordzahl von 62 Toren ein Tränen mehr
im Mailänder San Zero Stadion zum
Abschied für das Problemkind das zum
Weltstar wurde
schade eigentlich solche Typen werden ja
leider immer seltener
danke
und zum Schluss noch das hier die
berühmte Prachtstraße in Paris die
champs- und funktioniert am Wochenende
zu einem riesengroßen Klassenzimmer
Hefte raus fertig machen zum Diktat und
1.700 Schülerinnen und Schüler haben
einen Text von alfonso.de aus dem Jahr
1868 aufgeschrieben
möglichst fehlerfrei versteht sich der
Weltrekordversuch glückte
1.397 Diktate wurden von Guinness Buch
der Rekorde anerkannt außerdem setzen
die Menschen in Frankreich ein Zeichen
für Bildung und Sprache
für die meisten ändert sich beim Wetter
wenig im Osten und Südosten breiten sich
allerdings Regenfälle aus näheres gleich
von Katja horneffer das heute journal
können Sie um 21.45 sehen mit Marietta
Slomka und an dieser Stelle begrüßt sie
morgen Barbara halweg auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt kommt ein bisschen
mehr Bewegung ins Wetter und zwar hier
von Südosten dazu heute schon
wolkenfelde herein die brachten auch
schon Regenschauer und Gewitter mit und
diese Regenwolken die breiten sich jetzt
im Laufe der Nacht weiter nach Norden
aus dann regnet es hier am Nordrand des
Erzgebirges recht kräftig und auch in
Bayern fällt Regen die Temperaturen sind
noch sechs Grad in Schleswig-Holstein
bis 14 Grad in der Lausitz am Main oder
auch an der Donau und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 16 Grad an der
Nordsee oder auch im Vogtland sonst
werden bis zu 27 Grad erreicht z.B in
der Uckermark am nieder und auch am
Oberrhein und daran sehen Sie schon wo
es morgen die dichtesten Wolken gibt
nämlich im Süden und im Südosten es
regnet also recht kräftig in Sachsen
aber auch in Thüringen bis zum Abend
erreichen die Regenwolken das südliche
Niedersachsen Sachsen-Anhalt und
Brandenburg und dann geht's auch einige
Gewitter z.B auch in Bayern sonst
bleibt's bei Sonne und Feuer und in den
nächsten Tagen änder sich an diesem
Wetter wenig am Mittwoch gibt es nun
auch mal Regenschauer im Westen
Deutschlands der Donnerstag wird
ziemlich durchwachsen der Freitag dann
heiß am Oberrhein und da ist im
Nordosten kaum regnet bleibt bis Freitag
die Waldbrandgefahr hier im Nordosten
sehr hoch guten Abend